the surveillance State can keep you on
the straight and narrow it can people
don't want to hear it but it's true I
mean this is how a lot of those
anti-porn apps work I think it was Matt
frad really great podcaster was talking
about this that you get if you want to
quit porn if you have an addiction to
porn you get some of these apps and
services that basically whenever you
look at a porn website it just emails
whoever you tell it to email so it can
be a buddy it could be your wife it
could be you know and and so it's a it's
a voluntary kind of surveillance but if
you know voluntary or not if you know
that every single thing that you type
into your computer is going to be seen
by somebody else you're probably not
going to go to that naughty website that
you want to go to if you're living in
China saying you know all your searches
are going to be seen by the government
you're also probably not going to Google
things like democracy or how to lead a
political revolution or things like that
but even just in our personal lives if
we know that somebody is watching we're
probably going to be a little better
behaved